[Music]
it on august 30th
and it's today is november uh 10th
i mean how is it possible that the
department doesn't know how many
immediate family members are still left
i think in afghanistan i don't have a
number for you we believe it's uh
certainly uh
most likely in the dozens
but
one of the reasons we put the memo out
last week was to encourage service
members to come forward
embarrassing the pentagon taking heat
and they should over its efforts to
rescue family members or lack thereof of
american troops still stranded in
afghanistan and our allies our next
guest served on the front lines of the
war on terror as members of the elite
navy seal teams and now are running for
congress retired navy seals sniper brady
duke is here running for florida's
seventh congressional district retired
navy seals senior chief
derek van orden wants to represent
wisconsin's third district
almost got it last time he wants it this
time eli crane joined the navy days
after 9 11 and is running in arizona's
first district very very successful
businessman and morgan latrell served in
multiple tours in iraq and afghanistan
is aiming to represent texas eighth
congressional district and retired navy
seal and former interior secretary ryan
zinke is running for montana's brand new
second district they join us now to
react
first off congressman zinke i'm going to
start with you
how was that acceptable that admiral
kirby a spokesperson
for the pentagon cannot tell us who is
left behind and doesn't seem that
interested
well you know your point is excellent
and where is the congressional
investigations this is a biden-created
crisis that we've left our
family members we've left our allies
hanging in the winds and not only has
our government not been helpful of
getting our people out they have been in
many cases the obstacles
now i'm contacted every day by
individuals that have interpreters
family members that need to get out of
that country and in many cases our state
department under this administration has
not only been not helpful they are the
chief obstacle of getting our people out
we should have investigations and get to
the truth about what's going on uh eli
you know what they said well we offered
19 times to get them out but what they
say is you can go but leave your family
behind what person is going to leave
their family behind in that place and
just get on a plane by themselves and
now the administration says well we made
him an offer
eli you're right and it's just uh one of
them yeah it's just one of the many
issues that are destroying this country
i think we all recognize it that's why
you have five navy seals on the screen
who are all running for office because
we want to serve this country again
we need your help we need you guys to
get on our website support us and we
also want you guys to
go become precinct committee members we
also want you to run for school board if
we want a government that's of for and
by the people we got to start acting
like it enough about party and start
thinking about the country
i want you to take this in morgan this
is the pentagon spokesperson admiral
kirby who i know is a good guy i think
he's subjected to bad policy this is
what he actually said when it came to
threats to america
which is a bigger threat the climate or
china both are equally important
both are
are challenges that the secretary wants
the senior leadership at the pentagon to
be focused on as well as many others too
morgan who should we be more concerned
with the planet dropping one degree or
going up one degree or china's navy
which is surpassed hours and the way
they plowed over hong kong they're
looking to take over central and south
america economically and who knows what
else what's a bigger threat to morgan
latrell
obviously china china i mean the navy is
one thing but they're cyber security
threats they're pumping billions of
dollars into
their cyber
cyber platforms which we're not looking
at in my opinion i'd like to add this
about the afghanistan issue
if the bite administration is so
concerned about saving american lives
with these mandates and these mass
mandates and so on and so forth why
don't they mandate we rescue our
citizens and save their lives as well
over in afghanistan well i was fortunate
enough to run into an interpreter that
served with us overseas for so long uh
in the past couple of weeks and his
family's still over there and he he
pleaded with us he begged us he's like
who do i need to get to help me get my
family over he spoke perfect english
where's that in all all biden has to do
is say let's do this let's mandate this
task milli task austin and go get our
people it's it's if they if right if
they're pumping that much big pharma is
pumping that much money into the dnc
that all you're hearing on the news is
about mandates and vaccines why don't we
get some people to say the same thing
about our citizens overseas and bring
them home uh yeah or the allies that
helped you guys for 20 years hey brady
if the president doesn't say that and
you are austin or millie how could you
wear the uniform and just move on to
something else i know it's the commander
in chief but at what point is the
breaking point when it comes to red
white and blue and serving a president
that's indifferent to a war he says he
lost faith in
yeah you know i think it's it's it's
really sad to see the the leadership at
this point seeming to to be careless
about taking responsibility for
what was a botched withdrawal and i
think withdrawal is is going too far i
think it's really just a retreat you
know you can't say that it's a success
when you turn your back to the enemy on
the battlefield you know while there's
americans
that we must we must rescue from this
country
um right you know i think that
we have to we have to understand that
this was a failure that this was a
failure and we cannot continue this way
it was deeply un-american it's not fair
to you guys you deserve better someone
made the final decision while you fought
for 20 years it is just not fair real
quick what is great for us is that
you're here on veterans day and you're
still trying to give back only in a suit
instead of a uniform let's go around
starting with you congressman zinke who
served as secretary of the interior uh
what are your thoughts today
you know the level of sacrifice that has
been made particularly you know to our
veterans and the first line guys and
their families you know the day is a
celebration of how great the character
is of our veterans and our military
we have challenges but i think you're
absolutely right it's red white and blue
and let's take back this country
congressman excuse me not congressman
but eli crane you want to be a
congressman your thoughts today because
a lot of people are suffering because
they see what happened in late august
and they know there's two weeks left in
december to get people out but the
winter gets too tough but what are your
thoughts on veterans day
eli well my thoughts are this freedom is
always one generation away from
extinction we have to act like that
these guys are willing to go serve the
time for complacency is over
and you can see how quickly this radical
ideology can destroy this country if we
don't do something about it derek van
orden
hey listen uh today is veterans day as
we said i want to say thanks to every
single man and woman that has served our
nation given us freedom to begin with
from the revolutionary revolutionary war
and kept this nation free we owe a debt
of gratitude to our veterans we've had a
spike in uh veteran suicide 41 percent
over q2 to q3 and we need to make sure
that our veterans
understand that we love and care for
them and that the duty never ends and
another thing today that people don't
think about all the gold star families
who've lost men and women serving our
country deserve our eternal respect
that's a debt that cannot be repaid so
thank them today too if you also see him
absolutely and brady duke
yeah i think i'm proud of my service i
know many veterans are proud of their
service and i just want to say to those
who have served before me thank you very
much and those who have served
amongst me thank you very much you know
i have people thanking me for my service
and you know i think anyone who has
served in this military has played a
vital role
in in protecting our freedoms and
holding back the enemy and i think you
know we should we should definitely say
thank you morgan what's the name of your
pack you guys have formed a pack in your
mission to win next year
well before i get into that i i would
like to say something about veterans day
too because you've heard everybody on
the screen thanking thank you thank the
veterans i and that's the people that
are walking around that that are very
unassuming i walk up to them all the
time thank you larry thank you rick
thank you marcus
but i also say thank you to the spouses
because without them
we wouldn't be who we are today and they
made such sacrifices so when i share
my my emotions about veterans day i
always thank the spouses and i think
that's extremely important we should
never forget that
okay um
and the name of your pack ryan
is sealpack.org okay and uh it helps we
have seven seals now of three green
berets rangers so
we're supporting our patriots up front
all right guys always great to see you
thanks so much best of luck